vous avez de la chance parce
qu'évidemment en fait elle a tout piqué
une française qui est ici et qu'on a
notre célèbre c'est daniel barber
-notamment c'est quoi là où je t'aime
c'est que la prod nous a dit allez tous
en ferrain évidemment moi bombe à l'âge
comme juste me suis barré guillon ce
risque année je suis désolé j'ai pas le
temps j'ai très vite on s'est tous
battus et on a laissé leur victoire à
daniel il ya maghili berda qu'a joué le
jeu aussi et mâché éclairés façon macron
dans son rêve mais vraiment tout ce bar
alors est-ce qu'on a ma gueule et diana
c'est dommage que t'es pas baisser un
peu le site d'alien mais sinon la friche
magali tu vas le sait qu'elle a joué la
belle marion m'a dit faut que tu fasses
ça j'ai dit à temps mais est gâchée 36
ans a commencé par dire combien d'entrés
nous avons le temps que la voie mais
c'est très drôle tranchant durable mais
bravo d'année
c'est très bien que toutes ces photos
sont retouchées soit les filles sont
retouchées soit les photos sont
retouchées
il y en a marre parfois elles prennent
des positions ça doit être pareil ça
doit être truquée parce que moi je me
dis je vais avoir une entorse un temps
là cette file libère la parole et moi
j'étais très personnel à exactement
on sait bien elle elle nous impose une
réflexion sur les codes que nous avons
fait un mode et que personne peut tenir
donc et vous savez qu elle est suivie
par marion cotillard et le nom de
michelle obama et matthieu delormeau